you know faker as the greatest player to
ever play league of legends but in 2015
the most exciting mid laner in the scene
was spending a lot of his time playing
from behind a substitute in interviews
faker said he was willing to do whatever
was best for the team but actions speak
louder than words
[Music]
as 2015 began faker is coming off a
season that saw him try and fail to
carry SKT to Worlds but if anything that
season showed how incredible a player
faker really is even when the situation
around him is unstable near the end of
that year Ryo relief Azir while the
champion was released in September he
wasn't enabled for worlds but as the
earth intricate design made fans wonder
how exactly fascia would take advantage
of it between two of his accounts
faker played a 42 games on his ear in
2014 and while his winrate wasn't all
that high he didn't make some highlights
[Music]
the rules for the 2015 lck season got
rid of sister teams so faker and bengi
joined Maurin wolf and bang from t1s of
the mid laner from t1s easyhoon also
made the switch and as the meta started
to shift from assassins to control mages
it became clear that faker was gonna
have to share time even at the beginning
of the split wait wait what's this
what's this I spy in the SKT booth it's
that faker
it's easyhoon faker here's how we
operate we we pick our star player into
an unfavourable match and then we kick
him out when he doesn't do well in the
lck faker spent most of his time playing
champions like Ezreal re and a little
walk meanwhile easyhoon was playing
champions like Lulu
xerath and Cassiopeia but outside of the
lck faker racked up games on his ear and
solo queue he played a hundred and
thirty games on the champion in 2015
more than any other champion he played
for someone who's substitute was
supposed to be handling control mages
they think was spending a lot of his
time trying to master one but in week
six of the season faker finally got a
chance to show off as a series yes we
may finally get to see Baker's to see
here this would be very exciting we've
seen a lot of clips from it from some
acute yes happening it wasn't exactly
the debut fans were expectations trying
to protect that ward over the wall they
come in trying to take Baker Baker alt
Solar Flare those closing out he gets
that on the lantern though piccaboo man
this guy is good he's just always there
oh why would you recall there that q use
W life's puppet maker comes in will they
can't fake of the kill mar'ied be
Suetonius thicker needs to finish off
smeb right now we will but here comes
Lee that's an easy kill and fakers in
trouble - solar flare oh he gets out on
the lantern
nice play keep me gorilla way though
Kuro tries to come in there's this only
this faker two seats to go bang key
coming back corrodes gonna to change Oh
crow got the kill that's right in the
end after all said and done the GE
Tigers will come out of the first half
of season 7 and oh GG they've done it
SKT defeated - what
as both mid laners continue to share
time SKT finished 2nd in the regular
season
faker played 20 games and easyhoon
played 12 in the playoff faker was a key
part of as KC's reverse sweep against CJ
entus after easyhoon played in a game 1
loss fakers stepped in but when it came
time for the grand finals and yet the GE
Tigers Baker set out the entire series
with easy than playing mid with
Cassiopeia a Nazir to sweep their
opponents
[Music]
see with done with easy thanks to three
Oh
Baker took the opportunity in a postgame
interview to say he was happy that his
team won but he was willing to do
whatever it took to make sure he could
play in key Series in the future as SKT
prepared for MSI the question of their
mid lanes still remained both days to go
before the tournament Baker was still
practicing as year in soloqueue at MSI
faker get another chance to pull out the
easier but maybe in the least risky way
possible against tournament underdogs
mystique this eSports Club still it was
his birthday and fans ate it up faker
closer but he doesn't have that much
mana energy trying to get away energy
throws down his ignite faker throws down
the Clegg's
1v1 faker got the players here two more
times that tournament but the time grand
finals rolled around he was riding the
bench for the first three games against
EDG however they put faker back in with
Kassadin for Game four forced to Game
five and eventually his undefeatable
Blanc was countered in the final game of
the series he still has eyes on the rest
of the team elixir of sorcery on him as
well to get out a pan of extra damage
Goro finds him with the twisted advances
he
- distorts it SK Telecom t1 her wiped
the Nexus turrets are going down LPL's
Edward gaming are the 2015 midseason
Invitational champions we're turning to
LC k for the summer the narrative of
faker was still the same he was an
incredible talent but there were things
easyhoon could do that faker just
couldn't cross dreams of broken wings
that's right okay oh don't use his Oh Q
comes in bengi there as well there's a
double kill for Oh comes in though who
gets the double kills through easier
than rather faker was playing more games
but he's a little was still considered
the better Azir player even though Fay
who was grinding out games in soloqueue
bakery to get another chance to show
houses here had progressed until week 7
playing a 0 & 9 span you sonic boom
faker played his ear into Bell cause and
he picked up his first lck win on his
ear but just merrily
there's too much from SK Telecom right
now sausage just joining the fight it's
got to get a people bailed into the wall
after the rise route prison
and scottson that's the kill to maker Oh
double and in the end SK Telecom is
going to win this game har doesn't even
look happy after that game I wouldn't be
happy if I was SK Telecom t1 got taken
to the brink by a mid Bell cause
strangely this seems to be the turning
point for fakers Azir he played as here
two more times that season going up
against the Koo Tigers and CJ entus
winning both times as SKT entered the
playoffs in first place they only had to
beat kt rolster this time easyhoon rode
the bench as faker played all three
games playing ribbon diana and as he and
responsible SKT couple decided to take
some damage here we go
are they gonna go way far it goes the
faker a lot of trouble though gets it
with the assumption our enclosures
and preserve I'm very patient use on
that one goodbye dog name a kill for
barn and bang touched in the back
to find space someday finally it's mega
gnar right before he's taken out by
Baker SKT brought easyhoon to worlds but
Baker still played the lion share the
games the tournament the juggernaut
packed to hit the four worlds owed
changed the water with a pic ban
priority and Baker played a lot more
rise and then he bit at the scene and in
their grand final series against the Koo
Tigers
it was faker not easy who was in for
every single game easyhoon left for
China after 2015 and noted that while he
was willing to share time and make
sacrifices for SKT the shadow of the
unkillable demon king was older than he
expected and as it turned out faker
picked a pretty good time to get good at
Azir in 2016 he became known for his
unbelievable playing on the champion
either way it flows SKT even and fake
you're looking to make it more than
equal going in for Shou who one more
attack and now SK Telecom jaesik Bakker
already with the disk of the Sun where
the turret used to be nice upper survive
gets cusan and pilot not Sanaa cup so
Baker gets very low van SKT all over
this teamfight trace the last ones
standing that's a double kill for Baker
what a play out that is ear even the
2015's control major meta was perfect
for easyhoon Baker had surpassed him
even the Great's and League of Legends
have bad meta their picks they struggle
with but faker set out to prove that
those limits don't apply to him and he
did thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]